movie ignores the miles east this is
from Barcelona because it's just Spain
races now this is the most convenient
tossed overboard timing ever if this guy
had slacked off on the job just 4% more
born ordered round stuff I don't need to
see in order to believe it happened and
trying to help this guy but what the
hell
also open his existing healed scar just
to snoop about inside his body rage or
amnesia or not borne decides that the
best course of action is choking the guy
who needs to speak in order to give him
information what's your name I don't
know amnesia fishing boat makes a guy
with bullet wounds work for his supper
Slav norris form grabs this baton and
the other guard decides not to at least
try to beat borns brains it so he's got
the innate amnesiac knowledge to speak
german and disarm two cops but not to
avoid sleeping in the most obvious
discoverable place possible he goes on
to claim that he's just survived an
assassination attempt things you could
have heard in the tape if i just let it
play but decided to stop it so i could
talk about what he says in the tape
unless you confused it for Gemeinschaft
bank cleveland i don't know where he
rested after beating up those cops but
he should have picked that in the first
place he'd still have a jacket here's a
visual roll credits handy American
Embassy is here just in case you're
being chased by cops at this very moment
I'm an American something my passport
should be able to tell you but I'll
emphasize this point mainly because I
like bragging about it guy who's just
been informed that Bourne is wanted for
assaulting two cops decides to make a
scene in the US Embassy rather than
trying to take him down quietly which
also gets borne some time to plot his
escape
guy with gun waits until he's in borns
gun grabbing range to pull out his gun
horn casually checks the evacuation plan
and assumes there's absolutely no guards
up here ready to take him out
with no room to get the proper momentum
to kick the door open Bourne succeeds
because American engineering I guess
also what's up with this fire exit
why isn't an American Embassy fire exit
up to code is this the haunted section
where nobody goes so they said that when
it came to safety
this bag falling to the ground reminds
me that guards rarely ever seem to check
the back exits of a place when it comes
to chases like this these guys taught
the people an Incredible Hulk had a hunt
down people who in turn got the fast
five guys
this dummy doesn't see the obvious red
backpack in the snow below well I
personally think this free climbing down
the building scene is rad I have always
wondered why the high-security US
Embassy has no security cameras outside
the building to catch this kind of or
even him in the alley here in a minute
I see ledge proves no match for Jason
Bourne's icy grip as snow is just pretty
to look at and causes no problems in
situations like this
Murray casually walks to her car
seemingly unaware of all the commotion
in the embassy despite the fact that she
was just there a second ago and I guess
they're just letting people leave during
the manhunt they don't go on lockdown
also good thing she illegally parked in
this alley where you clearly can't park
a car or else Bourne would have had to
make his escape on foot and wouldn't
have a love interest still nobody
checking the back exits huh oh I see the
embassy itself doesn't have access to
the exterior security cameras but the
CIA back in America does got it sounds
dumbest but I got it doesn't it seem
strange how many white oscillating fans
there are in this room especially since
none of them are on wouldn't you think a
room stuffy enough to require this many
fans would be consistently stuffy enough
for a few of them to be running zoom in
enhance cliche little like her order go
deep those are two conflicting
statements words on screen and super
conspicuous Eiffel Tower shot team up to
make for damn sure you know this Paris I
can tell you the license-plate numbers
of all six cars outside but what I can't
do is memorize an evacuation card
without stealing it or change into some
different clothes or do anything
disguises 101 when it comes to laying
low seriously who does that
Marie thinks she's in a horror movie
where she can just be a jump-scare dick
willy-nilly not that Marie has shown the
best judgment when it comes to parking
but can you really park here and
remember she parked here and left born
in the car sleeping and then walked to
get breakfast somewhere I mean this is a
pretty shot but I don't think this is
where you want to beat you when you're
trying to avoid conflict Hey look girl
fight
I wonder if Universal was pissed about a
Sony movie getting into their shop
either that or its product placement for
a movie that came out in 2000 in a movie
that came out in 2002 sure this is Holly
yours
the guy just paid you twenty thousand to
come here I'm guessing yes okay so she
either took the two
brush that was already in here which ill
or she carries around a toothbrush at
all times she didn't bring her bag or
anything with her
so how bizarre is anything wrong wait a
minute was this guy here the whole time
if so what the hell is he crashing
through windows for and if he just
arrived where the hell did he come from
they're up several flights of stairs
so did he scale the building or get on
the roof there was no way professional
killers do business like this Bourne
disarms the guy have his gun but somehow
this dude doesn't have another gun and
now he's oh good a knife what did you
pack in that backpack you have snacks
where's the pistol ma'am I was amazing
to sins off for that badass hurry right
there I don't know how you managed to
get up under his own power since Bourne
broke one of his legs but oh well one
less bad guy I guess okay I'm sure he
killed the landlady but how did he get
in and why did he then concoct that
stupid plan to crash into borns a permit
there's a body in the streets there's
police this is terras how did Conklin
rise to boss level while being this
stupid well someone didn't see get
shorty how does this guy not realize
he's gonna be caught on camera entering
or being in this public train station
last chance Murray Murray risks her life
and decides to stay with the obvious
amnesiac assassin because the power of
borders is stronger now it's a good
thing the cop decided to park their car
far away from the suspicious vehicle and
simply walk over instead of speeding
over to it and trapping them in Bourne
is a dick to Parisians oh you would not
see a billboard like this in America so
this scent is for America also three six
one five come we got a bump coming off
this is a distant cousin to the pronoun
game the totally undersell the imminent
danger for comedy sake game all the
alleys and stairways in Paris just
happen to be mini Mayfair sighs so that
this chase can happen mini sales today
which I understand to be solid basically
oh that growth to this movie and the
Italian Job this car has been made out
to be a clunker the fact that nothing
breaks to the point of incapacitating it
during this chase and none of the bumps
and crashes matter either is miraculous
also Paris only has seven cops
did he bother to take the time to hop at
that guy he's already swerved to avoid
the other car was clearly oblivious to
Thorne's car so that guy didn't do the
hogging movie unintentionally inspires
against traffic car chase scene and
Matrix Reloaded that was definitely not
all that great movie cuts from a shot
that has no yellow van in existence -
born using a sudden yellow van as a cop
obstacle or cops tackle the phone booth
door isn't even nearly open before the
car speeds through but in the next shot
this dumbass will clearly saw a car
heading this way found a way to open it
just in time for the excitement of
smashing glass bring your kids to them a
workday
distracted driving this girl can't dye
her own hair apparently whatever as long
as they bone I'll take any flimsy excuse
the movie can muster also interesting
that they chose the doggy style
formation for hair dye application
instead of any of the traditional
non-sexual hair dye application
positionings Wow if the barbering is
going to be this rough imagine what the
sex will be like jeez man does your dick
have amnesia - Jason porn Hey it's at
times like this that I say to myself
they definitely didn't use condoms did
they just wing it and hope for no
consequences I like to place time for
fingerprints but if they decide to use a
blacklight in this place it's definitely
gonna give us away hey everyone Eiffel
Tower again remember where we are now
back to the action
what kill me bet that can manifest for
shine irony what kind of war we are
fighting but that is okay a couple
things here first off the guy behind
wombosi is completely gone now and
second off the professor was able to
properly aim and kill wombosi
in the split second he appeared in the
window sure the cigarette smoking man
was able to tell the professor he was
coming down the stairs but how did he
time a name that shot he doesn't even
have a great view I can see more
reflection than I can see inside the
building
I need distances no one will be seated
during the Ocean's eleven portion of the
movie I also need a head cap basically I
need you to become super agent like I am
in like five minutes the movie has the
balls to show a Paris establishing shot
that does not contain the Eiffel Tower
the nerve so on Kane
I just had a meeting his case a person
with obvious important information is
constantly interrupted by condescending
douchebag cliche it says that he chased
the man off the boat and shot him twice
in the back and then the man somehow
survived all that blood loss was
unconscious for hours floating in the
water and never died because born
seriously almost all law enforcement in
this movie decides that surprise is not
an option when trying to take down a
lethal assassin let's just camp in front
of the hotel
this
is blonde she has already seen her
picture alongside his on a wanted sheet
so why is this moment some kind of
epiphany for her again why great police
work really brilliant Conklin would be
amazing at cinemasins
beg borrow pack tap bypass I don't care
what you do
Patriot Act born is a dictum erease
friends door and has no patience
whatsoever
the coincidental timing of born in
marine and the dude who owns the house
is inconceivable it's inconceivable
incidents that's a really good reason
for this bloody well better be she never
tells him the reason keep seeing to this
asset batmanning her but I'll move along
they've been sending information and
orders to this prick by cellphone so why
they need to bring ink and paper into
this now look I know they came here to
hide out but surely he knows that this
place is on the grid why he hasn't
already left with or without her is
amazing to me in fact knowing what we
find out later about how he's got a soft
spot for kids it's ridiculous he's even
agreed to stay here who bloody dose gone
missing the professor killed the dog
presumably because he too doesn't
believe in surprising born I mean did
everyone in this movie forget he's a
trained amazingly intuitive assassin
born just assumes the assassin outside
is not on this side of the house he
exits thankfully he's right but Jesus
man I thought one of the virtues of
being a cold-blooded sniper was patience
this guy has zero patience and decides
to completely expose himself in the
middle of a field instead of laying low
I gotta get out you had to start running
hasn't lonely done enough of that
already just once I'd like to see the
redial think all the bad guys mom or
sister Domino's Pizza okay great
he's got a good vantage point where he
can't be seen but we're talking about
top CIA operatives here don't you think
they'd narrow down the possible places
where he can see the bridge and still
find him anyway boy for a super agent
born sure depends on a lot of other
super agents to be terrible at their
jobs
god damn it every one of these cars has
an alarm Bourne finds a way to shut off
power inside the building without
shutting off power or alerting the
guards outside the building you hear me
yeah failed this is exactly what my
college girlfriend said to me on our
first night together in bed you're the
one who picked the yacht is a goddamn
strike point borin suddenly remembers
the important information about the
assassination attempt because Conklin
yells at him and we're at the end of the
movie or some reason Bourne didn't take
the shot here instead waiting until he
gun against head range so he could see
when beau sees kids and feel guilty
also how in the flying did he not know
about his family even before the amnesia
Bourne was an assassin with heart which
helps us root for him but makes him a
terrible assassin if we're being honest
there are a few guys here to go Bourne
but they won't
we attack one by one because each of
them have a confidence in each other's
individual skills that I personally do
not okay so this is kind of cool but
completely unnecessary
besides human shield does not work when
it comes to gravity I'm sorry to say but
he survives this we're supposed to
believe Nicky is about to kill born but
it's complet who is limping around the
streets for some reason instead of
staying put in the hotel room I guess
he'd be dead anyway but cool surprise oh
the Sears store yeah Marie doesn't
recognize the obvious Matt Damon voice
how did he find her anyway he has no
resources because he has to lay low so
did he just find this place in a phone
book or e-scooter Emporium
that's for Marie she's wanted by the CIA
so drop on in you hear I always thought
it'd be better to be a fake somebody and
a really nobody
you
just five days into the king crab season
captains already have their sights on
the next fishery Tommy how's the perfect
Nautilus strange
would you mind presenting your wand and
why should I do that it's the banks do
you know how easy this is for me
do you have any fuckin idea how easy
this is a fucking joke and I'm sorry you
can't do this I really am because I
wouldn't have to consider here and watch
you fumble around him get up Oh gift is
my soul there these butterflies in
Central America they're blue and orange
and yellow and they have poison in their
wings just enough poison to stop a bird
heart but the birds know this somehow so
they don't eat them I will not sit back
and watch my only son become a Jesus
what is it what do